diana est encore dans les mémoires le
mariage on l'a dit donc on aura lieu au
château de windsor presque neuf ans
après la mort de la princesse de galles
pour le prince charles s'est donc un
deuxième mariage une deuxième union mais
il n'avait jamais cessé de fréquenter
son ancien fiancé stéphane breitner paul
ii venait trente années séparent ce
baiser fugace de cette discussion plein
de tendresse après un match de polo en
72 30 ans durant lesquels le prince de
galles n'a de penser que pour la
roturière camille h inde
pourtant pas question de mariage pour
charles c'est diana spencer une jolie
blonde de 22 ans n'est de bonne famille
qui épousera en 81 l'héritier de la
couronne
près d'un milliard de téléspectateurs ça
y est les britanniques tiennent enfin
leur conte de fées mais ce mariage en
fait est un mariage forcé par la raison
d'état pas pour la princesse qui
n'hésite jamais à déclarer sa flamme
je suppose oui bien sûr ça veut dire
quoi être amoureux en fait depuis 85
charles et camilla se voit tant secret
c'est même un couple qui habite ensemble
alors que diana est sur le point
d'accoucher
humiliée pendant des années la princesse
de galles ne supporte plus sa rivale
qu'elle surnomme le rottweiler et elle
le dit devant les caméras en 95
un an avant de divorcer c'était un
mariage à trois ça fait 1 de true la
princesse diana meur fin août 97 à paris
bien sûr pas de camilla aux obsèques
auxquelles assistent toute la famille
royale mais quelques mois plus tard
charles montre officiellement au public
son amour de toujours et ce n'est que
l'année dernière que madame parker
bowles sera enfin accepté par les sujets
de sa majesté
même si on les met pas forcément on
irait la réserve que jamais plus gémir
commenté aucun des
aucun des dix commandants été l'objet
gérer c'est toujours d'une parfaite
unité dans cette fonction
pourquoi je pense que ça finit par
forcer l'ennemi le prince devra attendre
la mort de la reine mère en 2002 pour
parler de mariage
contre l'avis de queen mum charles se
disait prête à renoncer au trône pour
épouser celle qu'il appelle la part non
négociable de sa vie depuis ce matin
chars n'a plus besoin de se cacher